[Applause]
when pedro castillo won the presidency
one year ago he promised peruvians he
would stamp out corruption in government
and end poverty in the country
the farmer and rural teacher also
candidly said he was learning the job on
the go but one year around castillo is
struggling
he has sworn in four cabinets with more
than 50 ministers dismissed amid
political infighting
we are not here to be a circus the
country has put us here to work for peru
for development and a fight against
corruption
castillo himself stands accused of
corruption
the attorney general is investigating
castillo for peddling graft and
obstruction of justice for allegedly
orchestrating the escape of key allies
who prosecutors say may hold evidence of
the president's involvement in crimes
he is not the honest man we thought he
was he is suspected of corruption in his
awarding of public contracts perhaps the
most solid accusation against him is
silencing people who could accuse him of
being a criminal
when castillo won the presidency he
raised the hopes of poor peruvians who
saw in him a man who would better
understand their grievances but the
pandemic and rising fuel prices caused
by the war in ukraine have made
conditions worse and allegations of
corruption by the president have turned
the hopes of millions of peruvians into
anger
his presidency has been marked by
constant protests claiming castillo is
incompetent and corrupt opinion polls
show his approval rating is at a low of
just 19 percent with most former
presidents either under investigation or
convicted of corruption peruvians say
they want him out
we want the truth to be known because we
deserve a president who is not involved
in corruption
but the president says he's innocent and
still some supporters give him the
benefit of the doubt
anyone can be investigated but until
there is a sentence there is no guilt
castillo has unsuccessfully requested
the attorney general and the probes
while the president cannot under
peruvian law be tried or sentenced while
still in office his political enemies
are working hard to ensure that he'll be
removed as president and sent to trial
long before the end of his official
five-year term mariana sanchez lima peru